what about miley cyclops
damn it that's good i don't hate it she
because she laser beams out of her eyes
she's raised
billy right
tom what are some forgotten marvel
superheroes that you think deserve to be
in the mcu
i was kind of excited about this one
it's a uh
so i think one of the the big complaints
that's sort of been coming in about the
mcu the last few years has been uh just
kind of the general bloodlessness of it
you know
that was something that came up in a lot
of reviews for black widow especially
you know you've got the
right the scene where florence pugh is
explosion proof
she stabbed someone in the stomach and
they're like
and then she dies but there's like no
blood
yeah
yeah
as a general rule you know that
not a lot of people
anybody whose contract isn't up is still
going to be around at the end by the
time that the credits roll you know
it's like that there was this immensely
bleak comic back in the 80s called
strike force moratori have you ever
heard of that no
it is
grim so it's uh it was a marvel comic it
read for a couple years back in the 80s
i think it only lasted 31 issues it was
uh the the concept is that earth has
been overrun by aliens and they're like
these nasty
it's it's horrifying they're like
they're popping the heads off of kids to
establish dominance and they're like
they're taking swathes of people up into
the upper atmosphere and then releasing
them down so that they they burn up as
they re-enter
yeah no it's yeah no it's really dark
and uh
and then this uh the scientist comes up
with this kind of like last ditch
attempt to maybe win this war and uh
it's that he figures out a process that
gives people super powers uh but the
problem is it only works on about five
percent of people they got to be pretty
young for it to work and uh
and if you do go through the process the
the stress that it puts on your body is
gonna kill you within a year
so it's this group of super powered
people who know that like whether they
win this war or not
they're gonna die
and uh
immensely
grim yeah no it's it's it's so dark
obviously like
it wouldn't necessarily work within like
the the mcu proper but with them
throwing all of the the alternate
universes and the what-ifs and the
different timelines i don't know it
could be kind of a cool standalone
thing i i don't know it would be it
would be interesting to see a story
where you don't know if the good guys
are going to win or not like on a
week-to-week basis sort of like a just a
constant ned start getting killed at the
end of the first season of game of
thrones but just every week you
never know plus you could probably get
in a bunch of great actors to do it if
they know that they're not devoting the
next 10 years of their lives
to this one project that they got to
keep doing over and over again you said
that was my first idea young though
that's my question is like would it
could you hire any actor to do it could
you could you play around with the age
thing like how young do they have to be
so in the comics the the ideal age is
like 18 to 21. oh cool okay but the
thing is that like if they uh they they
can put older people through it but the
process will kill them faster
uh
yeah it's it's a really dark story you
could get like
like a real a-lister in there and be
like like who's on the older side and be
like well you're just gonna die really
fast so don't worry about it sure yeah
yeah yeah i don't know i think that
could be neat yeah what's it what's this
called again
strike force moratori
is there was there any kind of lasting
uh ramifications on the marvel universe
after it wrapped up or
practically none it took place in a
different universe it was like it got
its own universe designation later on
down the line i think they made a couple
of references to it uh the last few
years maybe but yeah no it's it's it's
just kind of thrown aside
and it's weird yeah i i haven't seen
anybody
write anything about it the last few
years
but cool weird dark concept uh
alternately my second choice would be uh
nfl super pro
who was uh
i know super bro you know we all know
super bro back in the in the 90s there
was a brief and beautiful period where
uh
ex-nfl
superstar phil greyfield uh who blew out
his knee it had a sports injury became a
sports reporter i was interviewing a
super scientist nfl fan and received a
set of indestructible football uniform
clothes
yeah those exist during the interview uh
uh
criminals break in and rob the place and
there's an explosion of science
chemicals and nfl memorabilia which
grant phil grayfield the powers
of the nfl super pro
and he uses his sports powers to stop
sports crimes right
introduces a lot of great characters
you've got you've got the super villains
like uh instant replay who can travel in
time just a little bit
[Laughter]
issue 10 you get to meet a guy who uh
his superhero name is the almighty
dollar he gets the power to shoot
pennies out of his hands generally
considered one of the worst comics ever
made
wasn't it a tie-in wasn't it a tie like
a was it like a licensing thing between
marvel and the nfl it's half-and-half
half of the reason that they haven't
used the character again is because of
the licensing thing and then half of the
reason is that it's the worst idea that
anybody's ever had hi question
what's a sports crime
i need i can't
i can't leave this conversation
without knowing what a sports crime is
you know i'm not gonna i know about
crime i know about sports but i don't
know what a sports crime is
i think we all know what a sports crime
is okay i don't i don't i don't know i'm
telling you i don't
stealing first
i don't know if you could st you can't
steal first i mean that would be a crime
stealing any base uh
in football
in football
yep
those are my picks
uh any i'm sorry any further questions
about it i was gonna say though i mean
it's not totally out of the picture
right because
disney owns espn
and therefore football that's right yeah
to a certain extent yeah i mean there's
room for it to come back this sport of
football cause espn does air some nfl
games so maybe as part of the the rights
package next time they renegotiate a
project they say
yes maybe the next time the super bowl's
on abc they're like let's bring them
back
that's right halftime show featuring
super pro
javier bardem as nfl super pro the super
pro halftime show
yeah oh look at
this thing right that
was true i'm on abc write us a check
yeah yes please finally we have so many
good ideas
okay uh nina what are some forgotten
marvel heroes that you think should be a
part of the mcu well i only have the one
but i think it comes with endless
spin-off possibilities one is plenty i'm
sure perfect so in the 1990s um i
believe the year was 1994.
uh
yes uh it was a 1984 imprint through
marvel called marvel music and each
issue was about a different actual
musician so they did the rolling stones
they did bob marley alice cooper
and i'm not going to pick any of those
because those might be fun i'm going to
pick billy ray cyrus um who is
technically legally somehow
a marvel character because he has one
parenthesis one comic book so
in this comic book um he
like rides around on a horse a lot i
think there's two distinct stories in it
i tried reading it i couldn't get
through it it's pretty bad um
i just at a certain point i was like i
have literally a thousand better ways
just to spend my time um but
give us a broad stroke synopsis here
in one story that we could never do now
it is him fighting the ghost of a native
american chief um using not the term
native american so problematic on like
100 different levels but the second one
is similar to my dream what if story
where he's like rides through some he
gets on like a mysterious bus or
something and he ends up in the 13th
century and he has to slay billy ray
cyrus does
billy ray cyrus has to slay a dragon in
the 13th century yes this is a real
marvel comic where billy ray cyrus
fights a dragon that's correct century
yes and like all of this is the breaking
heart of a hero brian yeah and all these
start with him like walking around like
being billy ray and like people just run
up to him and are like oh my god and
then like something weird happens so
there's like
a weird separate thread where he just
has people constantly running up to him
on the street and losing their minds um
but the reason that i picked billy ray
cyrus is first of all easy casting and
play himself
i mean you don't need to like there's no
dreamcast in here true
but
would this open the door for miley cyrus
to be in the marvel cinematic universe
maybe
and that's something i'd much rather
she's already in it
she's already in the mic
wait what's she what's she
she totally is yeah man guardians of the
galaxy 2 when you get to meet the
original ravagers the original guardians
of the galaxy
i'm saying as herself she does
yeah dude miley cyrus so there's the
original uh guardians theme with
sylvester stallone and uh
there's like a there's like a robot head
that they have talking to them
yeah
yeah
no
yeah yeah
michael rosenbaum's in there as uh as
the crystal guy yeah all right well tom
you make a fair point but i'm saying i
want her to be in the marvel cinematic
universe as herself as herself
yes as the daughter of marvel character
billy ray cyrus
do you think that if there's any room in
the story for her to have like an
auxiliary personality that she i don't
know maybe like a secret
persona with which she uh i don't know
sorry my my i'm still reeling from the
discovery that miley cyrus
i think maybe occasionally she could
wear a wig and perform at pop concerts
i'm not ruling anything out that's an
idea i know we could do well with that
but no i mean miley cyrus
i love watching her do just about
anything she's a very charismatic person
so let's let's get the billy ray thing
out of the way and then all of a sudden
boom miley cyrus playing herself in the
mcu
i'm sorry i didn't mean to jump on the
fact that she was already in there i
just i figured no no the comments are
gonna like instantly fill up you're
right
it's distinct enough she's not playing a
robot head she's playing
potential alien human being miley cyrus
because she's kind of uh she's got the
bowie alien maybe you're not from this
planet kind of vibe going
what would the name of
her secret identity be like if you had
to make something up off the top of your
head
i really didn't want you to ask me that
because i can't think of anything um
i'm trying to think of a planet pun
maybe like
like
got nothing
um
jenny jupiter
i think that one might be taken already
with my
copyright on that one what about miley
cyclops
damn it that's good i don't hate it she
can shoot laser beams out of her eyes
she's raised
billy right
can you cut my terrible suggestion
thanks editing team
they're not going to cut it
okay i'd love this
now bro
yes
talk to us
yeah what's your favorite
uh
you're the one who told us to be here
today i have a couple pics
one is
i think a good pick but it's irrelevant
now but i'm gonna say it anyway
it's uh the incredible hercules
okay
hercules i believe was introduced in the
early days of thor comics as yet another
mythological guy who hangs out in the
marvel universe and in the years since
then he's just kind of become a lovable
affable large man who goes on adventures
and loves glory and so there's this
really great uh series of comics when
the hulk was out of the picture for a
while when he teamed up with a teen
genius amadeus cho i believe was called
the just the incredible hercules and
they just go on adventures and have a
good time that sounds fun so it is
really fun it's a great comic book
but
i think that he's irrelevant now because
they basically turned thor into him in
the most recent thor movie
maybe a little bit so yeah the current
thor is basically just incredible
hercules played by chris hemsworth
gotcha
did they kind of merge the two
characters
i mean just in terms of his his general
demeanor right because like in the
comics thor is still basically just like
you know big strong thunder god yeah
thundercraft exactly and then tycho ytt
got involved and made him fun and silly
yeah exactly right and that's basically
what hercules is so that would be what i
would want to do but again it's already
basically been done yeah so that was my
first pick i i love that who so i don't
know if you know that on twitter there's
like a low-key campaign that's been
going on for
about at least a year now to get like uh
that's what
uh
to get john gabrius you know that guy no
this is great comic uh really funny
actor uh
they're
trying to get him cast as hercules and
he looks just like i mean like it would
work really well but like who would who
would be your uh that was my question
who would be the dream casting
oh i don't know i didn't think that far
ahead
seth rogen i don't know why not seth
rogen
i don't know i have no idea this is the
first person that came to my mind
i have no clue
i retract it let's go back to rowan
atkinson again let's just make it real
making sense a great choice for her you
should play every part in the mcu thank
you the rowan atkinson cinematic
universe
my other pick was the great lakes
avengers
hmm perfect have we talked about that
before no i'm not familiar
i don't know if we have together but
yeah so there's the avengers and they
live in new york then there's the west
coast avengers and they're out in like
l.a
and then as a joke in the 80s i think it
was there were the
great lakes avengers and they live here
in the midwest great i believe they are
uh they were located in i want to say
fondulac
wisconsin
and uh they consist of characters like
mr immortal whose superpower is that
every time he dies he comes back to life
and that's it sure so he dies frequently
yeah
big bertha whose ability is to get very
large
what
man
right there's flat man who is flat
like flat stanley like the thing that
you have in middle school
not only i don't know what that was yeah
it was flat stanley she nailed it uh
he's like flat man
yeah okay he's like
tom is the bridge between us yeah um
thank you so
yeah flatman is basically like a crappy
or mr fantastic because instead of being
able to stretch he's just very he's just
flat
yes dinosaur who is a dinosaur woman um
and doorman who is
just like a living door
so he can teleport you but you have to
like walk through him
um and then later on back in the uh the
2000s they added squirrel girl to the
roster
and
they're great they're fun they're funny
i would love to see a disney plus tv
show of the great lakes avengers
basically questioning their very
existence they fight no one they do
nothing it's just a show about a bunch
of super powered people who are
um not sure why they're here but they're
making a go of it that was gonna be my
question is like who are their villains
what who do they fight what do they do
nothing i remember at one i think the
the the story that i read that i
remember fondly uh written by dan slott
was just um i think they fought
like death itself if i remember
correctly or
that's not where i saw that going i
don't i honestly don't remember they're
just saying the world unassuming
midwesterners and they fought death
itself like yes
they found a way it's so metallic
um so yeah great lakes avengers i i it's
a great comic book and uh
yeah that's my pick
for
that
all right now cast them cast it okay
yeah i can't do much of this squirrel
girl was already cast as uh malana
vaintrub yeah for a show that never
happened
um i know mr immortal should be
uh his name
has evaporated from my brain but kenneth
from 30 rock what's his name jack jack
mcbray that's it i remembered
immediately after i said it terrific
choice thank you
uh because he's he's got a southern
drawl
and he seems like the kind of person who
could die and get back up again and
keep on going with that infectious grin
yeah dinosaur is just a
a purple dinosaur person so no no no
actor necessary so barney
yeah uh yeah basically
basically
flat
man i don't know let's go with seth
rogen again
wow
big day for rogan yeah
seth are you watching this you just
booked so many roles you've booked them
and let's just give seth rogen the rest
of them seth rogen consumption fill out
the rest of the team
i don't know
it's been a high effort day here at
looper
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single
episode
[Music]
you